[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory a few
people had requested that I make this
video so here it is I've actually seen
this fan theory floating around myself
and in this video I'll just be
discussing it and letting you know what
I think the theory is a bit of a crude
one and it essentially states that
Voldemort baby or small form
let me see Pettigrew carrying around is
a result of fetus possession possession
is one of the darkest forms of magic and
we know that Voldemort is capable of it
so it might just be a possibility
outside of the possession that have much
to discuss
we know Voldemort tooth possessed Harry
Ginny Curel Ron briefly and numerous
animals when he was still in his Wraith
form another thing that we know is that
Voldemort could only possess things that
are attached to him in some way aka
interacting with one of his Horcruxes
let me expand on this theory a little
bit further before we dive in JK Rowling
has been quoted as saying that the rough
draft of the Goblet of Fire made her
editor sick to her stomach if this is
the case then this rather gruesome
theory sort of checks out it starts with
Bertha Jorkins who was a witch and
Ministry of Magic employee she was a few
years ahead of James Potter Sirius Black
Remus Lupin and Peter Pettigrew when she
attended Hogwarts in 1994 Bertha Jorkins
made the unfortunate decision to take a
trip to Albania as we know Voldemort and
Pettigrew were in Albania at this exact
same time Pettigrew a former pair of
joke ins convinced her to take a stroll
with him into the woods it was here that
Voldemort who was hiding in Albania at
the time tortured and murdered Bertha as
we know in order to create a Horcrux
Merlot is necessary so in killing Bertha
Voldemort was able to turn his snake
Nagini into a Horcrux the same Horcrux
that Neville cuts open in the Battle of
Hogwarts
this is where the dark and twisted
theory comes into play the theory is
that when Pettigrew killed Bertha she
was actually pregnant and that Pettigrew
took the fetus from her corpse
it was the same fetus that Voldemort
possessed and that Pettigrew dumped into
the cauldron with the regeneration
potion this of course means that the
body that we see Pettigrew carrying
around is nothing more than a possessed
fetus and the unborn child of Bertha
Jorkins some people have made an
exceptionally crude argument for Peter
actually impregnating Bertha to produce
the fetus but this doesn't work out with
the timeline and is quite awful to think
about okay so what do I think I think
that this theory actually checks out in
a lot of ways first of all it would
certainly be gruesome enough to make
Rowling's
editors sick to her stomach particularly
if Peter did any sort of impregnating
secondly we know that in order for
Voldemort to possess something it needs
to be related to a Horcrux in some way I
think the fact that Bertha was killed to
turn the guinea into a Horcrux is more
than enough to support that Bertha and
her unborn child are related to
Horcruxes in some way thirdly it
definitely makes sense with regards to
Voldemort's physical form he doesn't
seem to be quite baby but also not quite
creature his form is underdeveloped in a
lot of ways and we also know that the
act of possessing something can result
in some unfavorable changes in physical
appearance and lastly assuming that
Bertha was already pregnant it all
checks out with the timeline we know
that Bertha was murdered in 1994 and we
know that Voldemort gets his body back
on the 24th of June 1995 assuming Bertha
was murdered late in 1994 and the size
of Voldemort's physical form in June
1995 would sort of make sense the
problem with this theory however is that
we know that Voldemort is the recipient
of the rudimentary body potion the
rudimentary body potion is essentially a
dark potion composed of unicorns blood
Nagini snake venom the purpose of the
potion is to help to restore
noncorporeal wizards to a rudimentary or
more basic form
was this potion that was able to create
a rudimentary body for Lord Voldemort's
disembodied soul fragment to be directly
transferred into the body is described
as being small about the size of an
average baby and wrinkled with red and
skills him in a way this sort of
contradicts the above theory because
it's basically just stating that his
physical form was purely the result of
the potion however in his spectral form
it's hard to say how he would have
actually ingested this potion this is
where the theory still has some merit as
Voldemort may have possessed the fetus
in order to ingest the potion and
alternatively Voldemort spectral form
may have just been submerged into the
liquid potion resulting in his physical
form and that's all for this video what
do you guys think leave your thoughts
down in the comment section below I'd
love to hear what you think about this
until next time euro is it Harry
[Music]